Sidney Poitier the first black man to
win the Academy Award for best actor has
died recovering and speaking to his
caregivers he says I don't want to die
and he said if I do maybe you'll learn
something to help others Novak Djokovic
has lost the chance to defend his
Australian Open title after a court
upheld the government's decision to
cancel his Visa the American singer and
actor meatloaf who sits of course
included bat out of hell has died it is
quite clear that the mayor no longer has
sufficient confidence in my leadership
of the Metropolitan Police Service
for me to continue as commissioner
[Music]
you have to think maybe is this how you
get around the reputational damage come
out paint a smile on and act like like
you're normal and act like it's all
normal Ukraine has won the Eurovision
Song Contest in a huge short of support
from the rest of the continent following
of course Russia's invasion of the
country more breaking news now and in
America 14 children and a teacher are
reportedly being killed in a shooting at
an elementary school in Texas do you
find that Mr death has proven by clear
and convincing evidence that Ms heard
acted with actual malice answer yes
foreign
this is a seismic moment for life and
law in America you can see behind me the
protesters Gathering here some of them
celebrating and hugging it is clearly
now the will of the Parliamentary
conservative party that there should be
a new leader of that party and therefore
a new prime minister Japan's former
prime minister Shinto Army dies after
being shot during a campaign speech
they're not ready
[Applause]
they have done it England are European
Champions they have beaten Germany by
two goals to one history has been made
the author sir Salman Rushdie has
apparently been stabbed in the neck
while on stage in an event in New York
state we've joined a rescue boat because
water has rushed into this area
overnight and people have been stranded
Buckingham Palace has just announced
that her majesty Queen Elizabeth II has
died
[Applause]
police in Indonesia say at least 129
people have been killed after a riot at
a football match in East Java
I cannot deliver the Mandate on which I
was elected by the conservative party I
have therefore spoken to his majesty the
king to notify him that I am resigning
as leader of the conservative party I've
just been to Buckingham Palace and
accepted his majesty the king's
invitation to form a government in his
name at least 120 people have died
during a crush in South Korea 100 more
are thought to be injured following a
stampede at a Halloween event in the
capital Seoul at least 68 people have
been killed after a suspension bridge
collapsed in India's Western Gujarat
state
Pakistan's former prime minister Imran
Khan has been shot in the leg in an
apparent assassination attempt and the
United Nations says more than 8 billion
people now live on the planet we need
you we need more nurses for me to hear
that from my patient is reassuring
foreign